we we want drama we love story we like
the craziness but there's a line
anything that gets physical is the Lord
the line was officially crossed on
Monday night's episode of bachelor in
paradise
we saw the fallout from Christian and
Jordans fight Demi feeling torn between
her relationships and finally some use
of that l word drama that you just get
to sit back and watch let's back up for
a minute last week we saw Jordan stand
up for his buddy Clay's relationship
with Nicole which ended in a major fight
between Jordan and Christian Nicole's
other love interest and yes his white
pants got destroyed
after that they were both sent packing
we can't stand for it we can't have it
things boiled over one night and got out
of control
he's like the turd that won't flush
then there's Blake yes he's still in
paradise
he had his sights set on Hannah G last
week but this week
Hannah chose Dylan giving him the rose
over Blake at the rose ceremony and
Dylan admitted this while the pair
finally enjoyed a date night and I'm
sure I'm starting to fall in love with
you
hi
I am all in
their relationship isn't the only one
using the l word in a weird but totally
amazing turn of events John Paul Jones
and tisha are hitting it off big-time
you can find ice I'd be the happiest man
in the world Paul Jones the waters won't
stay calm for long the more John is
about to come out as Demi's still torn
between Derek and her girlfriend
Christian back home kind of downplaying
it a little bit
I really really think about her a lot
and I have so many feelings
let's have to hear these down
I know that fight for you is the right
word
of course life
how did things go for you paradise is
amazing it was so fun so emotional but
ultimately all worth it very very good
so much fun
we'll have to tune into Tuesday's
episode to see how it all plays out
spoiler there will definitely be tears